good morning John and I do not want to
belittle the importance of the case of
the poufy Nintendo but I think that we
also need to recognize that there are
bigger poops being put into more
important Nintendo's all across the
world right now that we need to pay
attention to
obviously BP is putting poop in the Gulf
of Mexico so Nintendo Israel and
Palestine have someone to poop in there
a Nintendo that nobody even knows where
any of it came from but much closer to
home for all of us on YouTube Viacom is
attempting to put poop in YouTube
Nintendo and this is a very big deal so
I invited you to ban Viacom the door to
my house and see that on my dining room
table and talk it out unfortunately both
of them ignored my request and so I had
to do it all by myself hello youtube
hello sicom your website is really
nothing but illegally uploaded
copyrighted content we want to very
reasonable things from you one we would
like compensation for the videos that
were viewed on your site that were
illegally uploaded and two we want you
to manually approve every single video
that gets put on your site okay look
let's take the first point first because
we might actually able to do something
about that it might make sense for you
to be compensated for your content how
much do you want for that we would like
1 billion dollars how about instead we
give you $2 per thousand views on all of
the content that was uploaded illegally
that's more than anybody else gets how
about 1 billion dollars ok well let's
table that for now but let's just be
honest here the vast majority of clips
on YouTube are uploaded legitimately and
legally by the owner of the clips
whether it's just some guy in his living
room or whatever last time I was on
YouTube it was like all daily show and
Family Guy clips um was that was that
2007 um maybe yeah well since then we
have cleared the world's most advanced
content identification system which is
all but eradicated illegally uploaded
videos from the site be that as it may
YouTube would never have gotten as
successful in gigantic as it is now if
it weren't for all the copyrighted clips
for example let me read to you from an
email from one of the founders of
YouTube quote if you remove
potential copyright infringement site
traffic and virality will drop to maybe
20% of what it is even if Steven Chen
meant to imply what that Barry
out-of-context quote implies Viacom has
repeatedly put its own clips on YouTube
trying to disguise the fact that it was
uploaded by Viacom how are we supposed
to know what videos you want online and
which one do you dumped that is not our
concern your site is built on piracy and
it is dirty we're so dirty and why did
you unsuccessfully tried to buy YouTube
what that has nothing to do with this
this is about our lawsuit you profited
from our content ah well is it true that
Viacom owned spike com routinely
monetizes videos created by independent
video creators with 30-second pre-rolls
without the permission of the owners
this is not spike calms lawsuit if those
people want to sue us they are welcome
to oh okay I get it now so it's okay to
steal from someone if they can't afford
a lawyer
the independent content creators that
you are stealing from they're the
backbone of YouTube now come on everyone
knows that independent content is a mere
sideshow when compared to the main
attraction of illegal copyrighted
content leaving aside that what you're
saying is infuriating it is also
factually inaccurate that's not possible
how could you to keep growing a thorn
profiting from pirated clips because our
users independent content creators major
media companies all these people are
uploading great content to YouTube the
people want to watch but they're not
watching our content and when they are
we can't control the way that they watch
it ah as far as we know that is not
against the law but YouTube you can
understand we can't handle this kind of
change we're an old media company this
this is the kind of change that we're
gonna make less money ah okay I see now
we have gotten to the crux of the matter
Viacom will you please take your poop
out of our Nintendo John I will see you
on Monday